rarement afin de recueillir
son retour d'expérience après 6 années
passées à la tête de cette autorité
publique indépendante et de faire le
bilan de son mandat bien entendu la
question de l'avenir des concessions
autoroutières a tenu une place centrale
dans nos échanges si ce sujet
suscite un vif intérêt au Sénat et dans
notre commission depuis plusieurs années
il est au cœur de l'actualité depuis la
publication en mars dernier du rapport
de l'Inspection Générale des Finances
qui a fait grand bruit il nous semblait
aujourd'hui essentiel de vous entendre
et de recueillir votre expertise en tant
que régulateur des transports sur ce
sujet désormais incontournable alors que
la date d'échéance des premières
concessions autoroutières approchent
cette audition est d'autant plus
précieuse pour la réflexion menée par
notre Commission sur l'avenir des
concessions d'autoroute que la RTA
publié en janvier 2023 son deuxième
rapport sur l'économie des concessions
autoroutières j'aimerais vous interroger
sur quelques points à la lumière de ce
rapport en premier lieu
élargissement des compétences de la RT
au secteur autoroutier en 2016
l'autorité a rendu pas moins de 17 avis
sur des projets d'avenants à des
contrats de concession qui portaient sur
un total de plus de 2 milliards d'euros
de hausse de péage le rapport indique
que les recommandations formuliers par
l'autorité dans le cadre de ses avis a
permis de limiter les de 15% les hausse
de pH supplémentaires pour un montant
d'économie évalué en 300 3 millions
d'euros
pourriez-vous détailler la décomposition
de cette somme et les leviers qui ont
permis de dégager cette économie
significative au profit des usagers ces
chiffres témoignent assurément de
l'efficacité de la régulation mais aussi
des limites du système concessifs
auxquelles Patty de certaines asymétries
entre les différentes parties du contrat
de manière plus globale à la lumière de
ce rapport qu'elle regarde portez-vous
sur les relations entre l'État et les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute et
celle-ci vous semble-t-elle
déséquilibrée
ma deuxième question porte sur la
rentabilité des sociétés des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes qui a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre ces derniers
mois qui suscitent de vivre des accords
nous avons d'ailleurs recueilli des
points de vue très divergents sur cette
question lors de notre cycle d'audition
comme vous le savez le rapport de l'IGF
rendu public en mars dernier fait état
d'une sur rentabilité des concessions
d'autoroutes par rapport aux projections
réalisées au moment de la privatisation
des autoroutes en 2006
en revanche la RT évalue le taux de
rentabilité interne des SCA à un niveau
proche des prévisions des contrats entre
6,3% pour les concessions récentes et
7,8% pour les concessions historiques
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur la
manière dont la RT appréhende cette
épineuse question et puis ne se question
sur la rentabilité des sociétés de
concessions autoroutières en quoi votre
méthode de calcul diffèrent-elles de
celle employé dans les travaux de l'IGF
ma troisième question porte sur la
manière d'appréhender le terme des
concessions autoroutières dans la
première échéance est fixée à 2031 en
mars dernier le ministre Bruno Le Maire
a demandé au Conseil d'État d'explorer
les pistes pour réduire la durée des
contrats de concession en cours selon
des informations
on n'a pas l'information officielle
selon des informations parues hier dans
la presse à haute juridiction
administrative c'est d'y défavorable à
raccourcissement de la durée des
concessions sans contrepartie mais elle
s'est montrée ouverte sur une possible
augmentation de la pression fiscale
pesant sur les concessions autoroutières
devant notre commission Bernard Roman
avait indiqué la focalisation des débats
concernant les autoroutes sur la durée
des concessions plutôt que de remettre
en cause le système actuel il préconise
de mener dès aujourd'hui une réflexion
sur la manière dont les futurs contrats
seront conçus pour parvenir à une
gestion des infrastructures plus
efficaces et plus équilibrée à cet égard
votre rapport de janvier 2023 dresse des
pistes intéressantes pour remédier au
lacune actuelle du système possessif
notamment en réduisant la durée des
futurs contrats en encadrant plus
strictement leur renégociation et en
favorisant un meilleur partage des
risques pourriez-vous nous exposer ces
pistes de réflexion
identifiez-vous des modèles dont nous
pourrions nous inspirer sur ce sujet
parmi nos voisins européens enfin ma
dernière question pour tuer la fiscalité
des autoroutes dans le cadre du plan
d'avenir pour les transports la première
ministre a évoqué l'idée de mettre
davantage à contribution le secteur
autoroutier pour financer d'autres modes
de transport à commencer par le mode
ferroviaire qui va nécessiter des
investissements très conséquents dans
les prochaines décennies quel regard
portez-vous sur cette proposition je
rappelle que depuis 2021 les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute remettent
en cause le versement de la contribution
volontaire exceptionnelle à l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport de France Lafitte compte tenu
de l'indexation de la taxe d'aménagement
du territoire sur l'inflation nous
pourrons d'ailleurs évoquer cette
question mercredi prochain avec Patrick
vergrid le nouveau président du conseil
d'administration de la fit que nous
entendons dans le cadre du même cycle
d'audition consacrée aux autoroutes dans
ce contexte comme en voyez-vous
l'institution de nous l'institutions de
nouvelles taxes visant le secteur
autoroutier monsieur le Président je
vous souhaite sans plus tarder la parole
pour répondre à ces quelques questions
avant de laisser mes collègues vous
interrogez et je viens vous dire d'ores
et déjà que devrait vous quitter aux
alentours de 10 heures ayant un
participant à colloque SNCF et c'est
Didier mandeli qui va me remplacer merci
je vous souhaite la parole monsieur le
président
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
tout d'abord vous remercier vous et le
Sénat de nous convier à cette rencontre
pour que nous puissions échanger sur
l'avenir des autoroutes dans notre pays
je suis venu avec la délégation d'abord
Sophie auconi qui est une vice-président
de l'autorité comme moi qui vient dans
un horizon un peu différent l'Assemblée
nationale
et je la remercie beaucoup d'accepter de
de venir ce matin et puis les services
avec à la fois le skater général et le
directeur des services qui suit plus
particulièrement les dossiers dont nous
allons parler ce matin et vous savez que
j'ai connu ce lieu par le passé et je
reviens toujours ici avec beaucoup de
plaisir même si évidemment pas mal de
choses entre temps ont changé parce que
le temps passe vite
alors pour pour parler un petit peu de
du sujet qui nous préoccupe pour m'avez
dit que j'avais le cas échéant 5 minutes
d'introduction donc je vais essayer de
mettre l'essentiel de ces 5 minutes sur
un sujet précis car si je n'avais qu'un
message ce serait qu'il faut engager dès
maintenant la préparation de la fin des
concessions historiques je l'avais
j'avais commencé à dire que nous avons
sorti le dossier aujourd'hui les choses
semblent avancer dans la bonne direction
et je m'en félicite vraiment parce que
nous avons besoin de nous en occuper
aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
le temps passe très vite et que si nous
ne prenons pas
dès à présent les bonnes décisions les
les bons travaux qui sont à faire nous
risquons d'être à court lorsque viendra
le moment de la passation témoin de ceux
qui pour l'essentiel dirigent les
travaux et gère ses établissements il
reste en effet que moins d'une dizaine
d'années avant l'échéance du premier du
premier contrat historique c'est une
durée particulièrement courte au regard
du nombre et de l'ampleur des chantiers
à conduire d'abord il faut s'assurer du
bon déroulement de la fin des
concessions en cours ça paraît évident
mais quand on gratte un petit peu dans
le détail quand on se rend compte qu'il
y a encore beaucoup de travaux qui sont
à faire et qui était prévu
dans le cadre des chantiers pour
lesquels les concessionnaires ont la
responsabilité
devant l'état et bien on se rend compte
que nous avons effectivement un ensemble
importants de travaux qui sont encore à
réaliser
il y a trois principaux chantiers dans
ce cadre qui ne puisse pas la liste ces
trois chantiers c'est premièrement il
s'agit de recenser l'ensemble des
investissements prévus dans les contrats
pour s'assurer qu'ils soient bien
réalisé avant leur échéance si on
regarde un petit peu ce que ça peut
représenter en chantier en travaux
imaginez que ça fasse un milliard voire
de milliards de travaux c'est donc pas
complètement accessoire
le deuxièmement alors que les contrats
de concession prévoit que les
infrastructures autoclières
autoroutières doivent être rendues en
bon état à leur échéance il s'agit
évidemment de définir clairement cette
notion de bon état pour les biens de
retour afin de chiffrer les travaux
associés et de mettre en œuvre le
programme correspondant difficile de
parler
de rendre un bon état si on ne définit
pas au préalable parce que signifie mon
état on avance mais c'est pas encore
terminé le troisièmement il faut assurer
la continuité du service afin d'éviter
tout interruption dans les circulations
aux autres routières évidemment ensuite
il faut anticiper les modalités de
gestion du réseau autoroutier à l'issue
des contrats et à cette fin est
impératif de poser sereinement les
termes du débat sur différentes
questions qu'il a aussi sont variées et
rarement simples et je vous remercie
monsieur le Président d'avoir d'ores et
déjà abordé ce sujet je vais y revenir
dès que j'aurai fini mon pourpoint
introductif on pense d'abord au choix du
futur modèle d'exploitation pour suivre
des concessions
nouvelle forme de partenariat public
privé mise en régie mais il faudra aussi
s'interroger sur l'éventuelle
redécoupage géographique du réseau
autoroutier ainsi que sur le choix de la
durée et les conditions d'attribution
des éventuels nouveaux contrats
d'exploitation sera également nécessaire
d'examiner les nouveaux investissements
à réaliser notamment en lien avec les
enjeux climatiques cette fois encore la
liste n'est pas exhaustive et négligez
l'étendue de ses travaux serait une
erreur ce serait prendre le risque de
manquer de temps pour les accomplir dans
de bonnes conditions en nous sommes face
à une occasion historique de faire
évoluer le modèle actuel
dans le choix du futur modèle de gestion
il faudrait être attentif aux modalités
de régulation qu'il a aussi ne sont pas
aujourd'hui pleinement satisfaisants j'y
reviendrai assez légèrement mais de là
où nous sommes évidemment nous sommes
bien placés pour en juger est indéniable
que le modèle concessif possède des
vertus il repose sur une logique
d'usagées payeur qui crée un cadre
propice à la réalisation
d'investissement et qui participent à la
couverture des coûts de la route ainsi
qu'aux objectifs de repos modal mais il
comporte aussi des imperfections dans
l'évacuation dans l'éventualité d'une
remise en concession du réseau la RT
préconisant particuliers deux évolutions
de modèles concessifs qui vise à mieux
encadrer sa rentabilité vous le disiez
Bernard romande déjà l'évoquais le
premier principal point qu'il convient
de réinterroger et la durée des contrats
car les contrats trop longs génèrent des
renégociations en faveur des acteurs en
place
parce que c'est uniquement entre l'État
et les concessionnaires et quand vous
regardez bien
il n'y aura pas de concurrence
et donc c'est des réattributions sans
concurrence sur des sommes qui ne sont
pas évidemment négligeables les RT
estime que les futurs contrats devraient
être plus courts que les contrats
actuels afin de permettre des remises en
concurrence plus régulière il faut bien
sûr mettre en balance les bénéfices
attendus d'une mise en concurrence
régulière d'une part et les contraintes
inhérentes à la gestion d'une
infrastructure routière d'autre part il
ressort des travaux de la RT qu'une
durée de l'ordre de 20 ans offrirait les
conditions de cet équilibre la durée des
contrats découle en principe des
investissements à mener
si bien que certains acteurs affirment
qui ne seraient pas possible d'envisager
des contrats courts si des
investissements importants devaient être
réalisés et laissent entendre qu'il en
résulterait nécessairement des pH plus
voire trop élevés nous pensons au
contraire qu'il est possible d'imaginer
des mécanismes permettant de concilier
une durée courte
des péages acceptables et si cela se
révérait nécessaire des montants
d'investissement important à la RT a mis
en exerce une solution en particulier le
mécanisme de la soul il s'agit d'une
approche parmi d'autres pour aboutir à
des contrats et aucune ne doit être
écarté à priori en tout état de cause il
est essentiel que l'État anticipe cette
question faut de quoi il pourrait se
retrouver contraint de s'engager vers le
renouvellement de contrat long et
montrer une occasion historique de
réduire la durée des contrats le
deuxième point porte sur les
négociations entre concédant et
concessionnaires qu'il faut encadrer
plus strictement par définition en effet
les modifications contractuelles sont
opérées en dehors de toute procédure
concurrentielle compte tenu de
l'asymétrie de négociation entre le
Conseil dent et le concessionnaire le
risque sans une régulation forte et que
les hypothèses servent de base à la
compensation octroyée aux
concessionnaires pour la réalisation
d'opérations donc prévu par le contrat
soit établie dans un sens qui n'est pas
favorable à l'usager et de façon plus
générale à l'état à cet égard peut-être
utile de rappeler que depuis sa prise de
compétences au premier janvier 2016 vous
le disiez monsieur le Président
l'autorité a été saisie 17 fois de
projets de modification de contrat de
concession ces projets portaient sur des
opérations que le consédant et le
concessionnaire envisageaient de
compenser par plus de 2 milliards
d'euros de hausse de péage les analyses
de l'autorité le conduites à recommandé
aux conséquents aux conséquents dans ces
avis consultatifs de réduire de 800
millions pas simplement les 300 qui ont
été retenus mais de 800 millions d'euros
ces hausse de péage sans dégradation de
la qualité du service rendu à l'usager
l'autorité a été partiellement suivie
par le consédant car réduit d'un peu
plus de 300 millions d'euros les hausses
de péage qu'il avait initialement
négocié avec le concessionnaire pour le
dire autrement d'une part ce sont
milliards d'euros qui part construction
ont été négociées de gré à gré sans
recours à un appel d'offres d'autre part
sur ce montant 500 millions d'euros
c'est l'analyse que nous faisions de
hausse de péage restait discutable selon
la RT alors je vais en deux mots en
parler un petit peu puisque vous posiez
la question sur sur quelle base est-ce
que nous nous sommes fixés la première
chose quand on a fait l'analyse de ce
qui était prévu dans ces contrats on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y a une part de
travaux
qu'il était prévu dans l'extension des
péages une par des contrats qui
prévoyaient des travaux qui étaient
d'ores et déjà prévu c'est-à-dire qu'on
allait le financer deux fois par des
hausses de perches successifs c'est
quand même un peu cavalier donc nous
pensons que la moindre des choses avant
d'aller aux conclusions il faut bien
regarder le détail de ce qui est prévu
alors parfois il y a eu des discussions
sur
l'analyse en disant oui mais c'était
prévu d'une seconde fois sans qu'on soit
allé dans le détail nous estimons que
les montants qu'on a vu au niveau de ses
travaux qui nous semblent déjà fait ce
sont soit 170 millions d'euros de
travaux et 300 millions qui ont été
retenus
qui sont venus ainsi tout simplement
chiffrés sur la base de nos services qui
ont regardé le détail de ce qui était
dans les contrats et de ce qui était
renégocié pour le financer une deuxième
fois
ça nous avait un peu surpris puis la
deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
aussi des discussions sur le montant des
travaux qu'on va financer par ces
augmentations de tarifs
parce que là aussi la question se pose
qui fait l'évaluation de des travaux qui
est à faire et donc nous avons mis en
place au niveau de la RT une cellule et
des données qui permettent aujourd'hui
de te rendre et nous estimons parfois
sur un certain nombre d'opérations
qu'elles étaient surévaluées nous avons
donc fait une nouvelle évaluation qui
nous semblait plus réaliste par rapport
aux coûts réel sur le terrain de ce que
coûterait les opérations et quand on
faisait le total de tout ça on arrivait
à 800 millions on a été entendu sur 300
c'est toujours 300 millions qui ont été
économisés
au travers de ceux qui payent les péages
sur ces autoroutes mais ce sont des des
choses qui pour nous sont importantes
évidemment il faudra que pour la suite
de l'existant il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement précis la prise en compte
limitée de recommandations d'art pour
amener législateur à réinterroger la
portée des pouvoirs qu'il a confié à
l'arrêter en la matière en effet nous
nous sommes là avec la possibilité de
donner un avis nous ne décidons pas pour
être imaginer
travers d'une la nouvelle examen des
compétences de la RT que le cas échéant
on puisse avoir une position qui permet
de s'imposer et qu'il conçoit obligé de
démontrer que les chiffres que nous
avons donné ne sont pas les bons
nous sommes prêts en discuter
que ce soit nous ou d'autres vous savez
moi ma durée au travers de la RT c'est
encore un an
ça ne sera pas pour moi mais c'est pour
l'efficacité du fonctionnement de nos
institutions et de l'utilisation de
l'argent public je n'imagine pas que
lorsqu'il s'agit de milliards d'euros on
puisse en décider sans avoir
véritablement au préalable vérifier
l'utilité et vérifier la réalité des
chiffres qui sont indiqués voilà
monsieur le Président c'est ces propos
introductifs que que je souhaitais faire
et si vous le voulez bien je reprends
tout de suite les questions que vous
avez posées autour de la question de la
rentabilité des concessions en réalité
quand on regarde bien
il n'y a pas tant d'écart que cela parce
qu'il faut regarder ce que nous
entendons
quand nous utilisons le mot rentabilité
faut bien comprendre que l'autorité
analyse la rentabilité des concessions
d'autoroute sous l'angle du pH payé par
l'usager précisément l'autorité mesure
la rémunération de l'ensemble des
capitaux engagés dans la concession
c'est-à-dire à la fois des fonds propres
apportés par les actionnaires et de la
dette sur toute la durée du contrat
c'est à dire depuis que ces autoroutes
sont en concession et pas uniquement
depuis 2006 qui était la période de
de libéralisation des propriétés des
autoroutes qui étaient l'approche qui
avait été retenu par
l'autorité
budgétaire de l'État donc nous avons été
sur cette durée totale pourquoi parce
que tout simplement c'est ce que nous
demande la loi la loi nous demande de
suivre cette évolution sur la durée
totale et donc que le faisons sur la
durée totale tout en ayant évidemment la
possibilité bien sûr de comparer car en
deuxième temps on peut se poser la
question à combien cette rentabilité
s'élève-t-elle les estimations les plus
récentes de l'autorité conclut à un taux
de rentabilité interne projet un
tri-projet pour les 7 principales
concessions historiques de 8%. c'est à
dire que les péages auront rémunéré les
capitaux engagés sur toute la durée des
concessions historiques soit de 64 à 75
ans sur la base d'un taux d'intérêt de
8%. c'est d'ailleurs là aussi qu'on voit
que la durée totale c'est quand même
relativement compliqué parce que c'est
entre 64 et 75 ans chacun aura compris
que c'est relativement long c'est trois
quarts de siècle pour les 75 ans c'est
parfois compliqué de le faire si on
était sur des durées plus courtes
évidemment ce serait plus facile dans ce
travail la priorité de l'autorité dont
l'action comprend a volé important
consistant à éclairer les débats publics
vous ai donné les éléments quantifiés
pour que chacun puisse s'il le souhaite
faire les comparaisons adéquates et
avoir sa propre appréciation de la
rentabilité des concessions en toute
état cause conclure que la rentabilité
des capitaux engagés dans ces
concessions historiques appréciées sur
toute la durée de ses concessions et
manifestement excessive est en tout cas
une évidence c'est ce que les travaux de
la RTD démontrent certes un théorie
projet des concessions abris pour cent
ça a l'air supérieur aux attentes
moyennes du marché selon l'estimation de
la RT elles étaient de l'ordre de 7% sur
cette période et pour un investissement
de ce type cela signifie qu'à l'échéance
des contrats la recette perçues durant
le contrat dépasseront l'écoute y
compris d'ajuste rémunération des
capitaux investis néanmoins compte tenu
des risques transférés et de la durée de
la concession cette écart n'est pas
incompatible avec les alliés normaux de
la concession les choses allant de 7 à
8%. troisième temps quelles conséquences
en tirer ces analyses ne ferment pas la
question du niveau de rentabilité les
débats actuels sur le tri ça mesure et
son interprétation ne doivent pas nous
faire oublier les vrais enjeux en
matière de régulation du secteur car il
s'agit d'un fait établi documenté
plusieurs imperfections du modèle
concessif actuel tendent à s'accompagner
des faits haussiers sur la rémunération
handicapists sont investie par le
concessionnaire dans ces travaux la RT
la constaté à plusieurs reprises je
donnerai aujourd'hui que deux exemples
le premier je le ferai de façon assez
courte les négociations de gré à gré
pour la réalisation de nouvelles
infrastructures sont souvent
avantageuses pour le concessionnaire
depuis 2016 le concédant a
contractualisé 17 avenants à des
contrats de concession correspondant à
une hausse cumulée avec 7 milliards
d'euros des péages les analyses de la RT
avaient montré que sur ce montant 500
millions d'euros de hausse de péage
restaient discutable c'est donc un demi
milliard de trop c'est ce que nous avons
estimé que les usagers financeront à
travers des péages deuxième exemple les
contrats comprennent des investissements
à réaliser notamment les élargissements
qui n'ont pas encore été exigées du
concessionnaire il s'agit pourtant de
montant important de l'ordre de
plusieurs milliards d'euros
si le Conseil dent ne fait pas valoir
ses droits ses investissements auront
été payés par l'usager sans qu'il ne
soit réalisé et là nous sommes dans la
réalité quotidienne c'est pas des choses
à l'horizon
4e temps quelles actions concrètes
peuvent être engagées je le disais dans
les médias une gestion rigoureuse des
contrats permettrait de contenir la
rentabilité des concessions durant la
prochaine décennie la qualité du pilote
pilotage du consédant impactera les
charges et les recettes des
concessionnaires une bonne gestion du
contrat contiendra la rentabilité dont
bénéficie des concessionnaires à
l'inverse un manque de rigueur pour
permettre une dérive significative les
enjeux financiers associés sont Colosso
moins gestion de la fin des concessions
pour écouter des milliards d'euros à
l'État l'avenir c'est le choix est fait
de maintenir des concessions
l'encadrement des nouvelles concessions
devront être renforcés les contrats
devraient être plus courts duré je le
disais de l'ordre de 20 ans qu'elle
maintient de contrats longs le cadre
régulatoire applicable aux avenants
doivent être revus pour être plus
contraignant voilà les réponses à l'une
ou l'autre des questions que le que le
président
avait souhaité évoqué dès le début il y
en avait d'autres
alors là nous sommes sur la question de
la fiscalité des autoroutes
pourraient-elles contribuer via la
fiscalité aux investissements dans le
ferroviaire
je voudrais rappeler que les questions
de fiscalité que comme celle relative
d'affectation des ressources de l'État
ne relève pas directement des
compétences de l'autorité c'est c'est le
Parlement c'est le gouvernement ce n'est
pas nous donc
j'aimais simplement des remarques mais
qui ne vont pas plus loin des
contentieux sont en cours entre l'état
des sociétés concernées sur la question
de l'indexation de taxe d'aménagement du
territoire et c'est au juge qu'il
appartient drap de trancher et
évidemment nous appliquons ce que dira
le juge je peux néanmoins apporter des
éclairages sous l'angle des conséquences
sur le péage juste petit point le
secteur autour
des gens au financement des transports à
travers la fiscalité spécifique à ce
secteur les taxes spécifiques payés par
les SCA la redevanced dominale et la
taxes d'aménagement du territoire
représentait 935 millions d'euros en
c'est pas négligeable presque un
milliard pour aller plus loin il faut
examiner les outils offerts par la
nouvelle directive Eurovignette qui
permettent de mettre en place des
redevances pour coûts externe il s'agit
de mettre en place un principe
pollueur-payeur il est ainsi possible
d'intégrer dans le pH la valeur des
rejets polluants des véhicules des
émissions de CO2 de la pollution sonore
ou encore de la congestion cela permet
de dégager des moyens pour financer des
modes de transport alternatif tout en
incitant à des comportements plus
vertueux c'est aussi un début de réponse
à l'autre question qui était de savoir
est-ce qu'on peut le cas échéant
financer du ferviaire sur la base des
travaux au niveau de
au niveau de des autoroutes
au-delà la RT a mis en évidence dans son
rapport de janvier 2023 l'effet
d'aubaine dont le CD conceptionnaire ont
bénéficié avec la baisse du taux d'impôt
sur les sociétés entre 2018 et 2022
et nous avions chiffré ce montant à 7,9
milliards d'euros jusqu'à la fin des
concessions historiques donc d'un côté
il y a 935 millions d'euros dont il est
question puisque c'est une ponction qui
est opérée sur les sociétés consonnes
concessionnaires
voilà
ça sera tranché le juge aura tranché
mais en même temps les avantages qui ont
été servis par la loi c'est 7,9
milliards
je n'ai pas en discuter
enfin je relève que si les questions
sont d'un milliard d'un côté elles sont
de l'ordre de 8 milliards de l'autre
donc nous avons l'occasion ici de de
voir qu'il faut évidemment suivre ces
dossiers de façon très précise de 900 si
le Conseil d'État ouvre la voie puisque
il a dit qu'il allait trancher ouvre la
voie à une augmentation de la fiscalité
fixant sur les autoroutes sans
compensation
par des hausses de tarifs alors il
faudra regarder comment nous pourrons
rééquilibrer les choses de façon la plus
raisonnable possible voilà les réponses
rapides à quelques-unes des questions
que le président avait bien voulu poser
et je suis
j'allais le dire je sais que on m'a dit
c'est uniquement un qui peut parler
enfin si sur un sujet ou sur un autre à
la fois les services ou
pouvait le caser chiant compléter les
réponses ou apporter une sensibilité à
laquelle je n'aurais pas pensé je
demande votre indulgence voilà
le président
les remarques préalables que je souhaite
que je souhaite faire merci monsieur le
Président pour l'ensemble des éléments
que vous avez pu aborder et puis surtout
pour les projections que vous avez pu
dessiner également sur de réflexion y
compris sur les missions de la RT pour
pour le Parlement
donc vous pourrez évidemment répondre
les uns ou les autres indifféremment il
y a aucune difficulté par rapport à ça
je vais donner la parole à trois de nos
collègues on va faire des par série donc
Bruno Belin ensuite en gel Preville et
Olivier Jacquin Bruno
c'est effectivement leur cette
augmentation du coût des pH finalement
sans autre justification de leur part
alors vous comme autorité vous avez
accès au compte des gestionnaires donc
pouvez-vous dire aujourd'hui si cette
hausse est légitime et je vais plus loin
est-ce qu'il y aurait un moyen de la
contraindre si effectivement vous
estimiez qu'elle n'avait pas la
légitimité tout simplement comptable je
vous remercie
merci Bruno Angèle la question suivante
donc merci d'abord pour votre
propos prix juste par là voilà pour
votre pour votre propos liminaire merci
pour votre vigilance très aiguë sur le
sujet et votre travail vraiment
d'expertise alors moi j'ai il y a déjà
des questions qui ont été posées mais
vous avez évoqué le bon état où est-ce
que vous en êtes ou est-ce que vous
allez établir une une feuille de route
en fait ou quelque chose dans ce goût là
pour établir ce qu'est le bon état de en
fin de contrat également vous avez parlé
de gestion rigoureuse des contrats et
moi je me pose la question après tout ce
que j'ai entendu est-ce que cela va être
suffisant ou est-ce qu'il va falloir
préciser encore davantage les contrats
voilà pour mes questions merci
merci gel ensuite Olivier Jacquin
merci président mandeli ravi de
retrouver mon ancien président de Région
Philippe Richert ici
j'ai plusieurs questions sur le sujet je
pense que vous avez dans votre propos
introductif répondu avec éloquence sur
le déséquilibre de la relation sans
jamais prononcer le mot déséquilibre
mais tous les exemples que vous avez
donné en atteste très largement et je
salue le fait que vous appeliez dans
l'éventualité d'un renouveau du
concessif à des contrats beaucoup plus
courts et mieux réviser régulièrement
alors moi j'attends des beaucoup de
cette audition sur un des points qui m'a
troublé nous avons et je remercie le
président engager un gros travail
d'audition sur le domaine des
concessions autoroutières et on a
assisté ici à une bataille de chiffres
qui est difficile d'arbitrer entre les
tenants du tri projet et les tenants du
tri actionnaire alors vous avez dit
votre
position très nette en faveur du tri
projet mais notre collègue Vincent
Delahaye qui était président de la
commission d'enquête des autoroutières
fustigent cette méthode et va plutôt
dans le sens de l'IgG de l'IGF
elle-même a saluer les travaux de
Vincent Delahaye et sa méthode pour
approcher la rentabilité des autoroutes
donc vous avez donné des éléments en
faveur du Terry projet j'aimerais que
vous vous positionnez mieux dans la
bataille de chiffres à laquelle nous
avons assisté qui a été partiellement
public et ça me semble un point
important d'éclairer notre
haute assemblée sur cette question là
deuxième question je porte une
proposition de résolution en faveur d'un
projet qui s'appelle route de France qui
a été un temps
porté par la haute administration en
matière de mobilité et qui contrairement
à bien des
biens des hypothèses n'est pas en
défaveur du concessif mais prône un
renouveau absolu et notamment la prise
en compte d'un certain nombre de
désordres et le premier étant le mauvais
état du réseau routier national non
conseillé qui n'est pas dans votre champ
de
expertise bien sûr mais en créant un
établissement public qui gérait
l'ensemble des autoroutes à la fin des
contrats à la fin des contrats ça veut
dire sans aucune indemnité des des
concessionnaires actuels on pourrait à
terme avec la directive Eurovignette
rééquilibrée un dispositif et en quelque
sorte fléchés l'argent de la route vers
la route dans un premier temps puis
éventuellement vers le ferroviaire je
vais en rester
là peut-être une dernière question sur
l'utilité de la RT
contre on sent que au niveau de
l'exécutif le renouvellement de la
présidence de la RT semble poser des
questions je suppose que vous n'allez
pas vous exprimer sur le sujet et vous
n'avez pas d'informations vous nous avez
parlé d'un la fin de votre mandat d'ici
un an et vous êtes bien président par
intérim voilà
c'est à dire que je suis vice-président
et le plus ancien grade qui me fait
revenir et j'en suis très fier ce type
de président mais nous travaillons
beaucoup j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire devant l'Assemblée nous travaillons
beaucoup de façon collégiale et
travailler de façon collégiale ça veut
dire que chacun y participe réellement
et comme nous sommes 4 vice-président ça
veut dire que chacun apporte sa vision
ça sa façon de faire et je crois pouvoir
dire que ça se passe plutôt bien au
début on m'avait dit certains
journalistes avaient dit Richard a été
nommé en gros c'est quelqu'un de la
droite pour contrer au manque était
plutôt de gauche et personne ne
contestera qu'il est plus qu'il était
plutôt de gauche mais ça c'est pas du
tout passé comme ça et aujourd'hui
encore les choses se passent de façon
très constructive et le principe dans
une collectivité ou dans une institution
quelle qu'elle soit c'est que chacun
apporte en fonction de sa vision de sa
façon d'avancer et c'est comme ça que ça
se passe et j'ai essayé dans ma vie
toujours de le faire de cette façon et
c'est plutôt positif et j'avoue qu'à
personnel j'ai beaucoup apprécié et
j'apprécie beaucoup travailler au sein
de la RT je me permets de dire aussi
accessoirement c'est juste un détail
grâce à la qualité de nos services ce
juste un détail mais ça compte aussi et
je sais qu'au niveau du Sénat le travail
des services est aussi très remarquable
alors si vous le voulez bien je vais
revenir sur les quatre interventions
d'abord
la question de la hausse des péages et
que les sociétés autoroutières ne sont
pas toujours très à l'aise
au départ il nous avait vraiment gris
pour tout dire
en expliquant que ce que c'est vraiment
utile
d'avoir une autorité
nous on était d'avis qu'on faisait on
n'était pas inutile
aujourd'hui c'est même autoroutes font
plutôt appel à nous pour démontrer par
rapport
à la position
des services fiscaux que
l'analyse qui est faite par eux avec les
11 12% bien sûr un sujet différent d'une
autre
était à relativiser et ça puis volonté
sur nos résultats aujourd'hui nous avons
fait dans le premier document l'année
dernière
un travail qui mettait les bases pour
qu'on comprenne bien de quoi on parle
notamment sur la question de la
rentabilité sur la question de
l'utilisation financière et la façon de
le cas échéant de remettre tout cela à
l'équerre
et ce support
était pour nous l'occasion de dire où
nous nous trouvons ce n'est pas à nous
de décider
ceux qui décident c'est c'est le
gouvernement et c'est le Parlement qui
décide nous on apporte la contribution
et on fait ce qui nous est demandé par
le Parlement en grande partie aussi par
le gouvernement un peu moins
lorsqu'il y a eu des avancées au niveau
des compétences de la RT c'est
particulièrement le Parlement qui a fait
avancer les sujets c'était pas trop le
gouvernement
et nous avions été lors des dernières
révisions à proposer au Parlement
Sénat compris
un certain nombre de ces propositions
que nous retrouvons ici il lui suffit
que le Parlement les prennent et c'était
réglé si je continue à parler c'est que
le Parlement ne l'a pas repris
et nous estimons à l'époque comme je le
dis maintenant que c'est nécessaire
parce que ça permet d'assainir la
situation nous n'avons pas d'intérêt
nous ne gagnions pas plus ou moins en
fonction de la vie que nous donnons nous
essayons sur la base des travaux très
sérieux qui sont faits d'apporter des
contributions pour éclairer le débat
alors niveau de cette façon d'éclairer
le débat
comment contraindre
la question qui était posée comment
est-ce que nous pourrions contraindre
si on donne la possibilité
à l'autorité
de décider au lieu de donner simplement
un avis au gouvernement
ça change quand même beaucoup la donne
nous ne voulons pas à tout prix
augmenter nos compétences pour avoir
pour faire de la gonflette
on le fait parce que nous estimons que
tant le cadre du renouvellement des
concessions s'il y a renouvellement des
concessions
on ne peut pas repartir avec les mêmes
bases il faut prendre un certain nombre
de précautions et parmi ces précautions
il y a entre autres la compétence de
l'autorité pour permettre tout
simplement que dans le débat qu'il y a
entre l'état d'un côté et les
concessionnaires qu'il y a une forme
d'équilibre puisque le concessionnaire
lui il est au courant tout et comment
voulez-vous après 50 ans d'exercices de
responsabilité sur des tronçons autour
d'iés qui ne soient pas mieux renseignés
que l'État sur les montants des travaux
qui sont à faire nous estimons qu'il est
indispensable que nous ayons
une égalité d'informations et nous
sommes là pour donner ces informations
nous les données régulièrement au
ministère à titre personnel moi j'estime
que nous n'avons pas assez de retour on
pourra en avoir plus
ça ne veut pas dire que nous prendrons
systématiquement la position du
ministère nous sommes là pour être
indépendant mais je crois qu'il faut que
dans ces années qui viennent parce que
c'est une correspond pas à juste à
l'autructure de régulation des
transports c'est valable pour toutes les
autorités indépendantes si on veut être
utile dans la réalité de ce que nous
faisons donc je pense qu'il est
nécessaire d'aller d'aller plus loin
alors l'autre question qui avait été
posée ensuite sur le le bon état je veux
dire que globalement nous avons
un réseau autoroutier celui qui a été
géré par les concessions qui est en bon
état
je me souviens encore du temps d'avant
il y a pas photo entre ce qu'il y avait
avant et maintenant on a beaucoup
beaucoup avancé comme je suis alsacien
je regardais évidemment souvent de
l'autre côté
ils ont un système autour routier qui
était sans comparaison meilleure que
l'autre actuellement je trouve qu'on
peut commencer à comparer
et nous avons un état autoroutier qui
tient la comparaison avec des des
autoroutes de pays qui ont une
réputation à la matière de depuis
longtemps donc il faut que nous ayons
l'occasion de continuer à traverser mais
il faut que nous fassions attention pour
que d'ici la fin il n'y a pas une dérive
qui s'installe et cette dérive c'est à
la fois le suivi de ce qui est encore à
faire parce que c'était prévu au contrat
si on ne le faisait pas c'est de
l'argent perdu et si je dis c'est de
l'argent perdu comme j'ai parlé de 1 de
2 milliards d'euros un demi milliard
d'euros c'est pas complètement
accessoire c'est quand même beaucoup
d'argent donc c'est normal qu'on regarde
ça de très près et puis la deuxième
c'est qu'il faut bien préparer la suite
parce que si jamais on ne la prépare pas
bien pour la suite si on
anticipe pas correctement il y a là
aussi on risque d'avoir des désordres
alors ça peut être des des
ralentissements voir des suppressions si
on n'a pas bien fait ou alors c'est des
nouveaux travaux qui sont à organiser et
ce n'est pas réaliste il faut rester
vigilant nous resterons vigilants et je
trouve que le débat que nous avons
régulièrement notamment avec les
sociétés concept social professionnels
ça se passe plutôt bien on n'est pas
toujours d'accord c'est pas toujours des
petites fleurs qu'on s'envoie mais sur
la base de choses qui sont établies nous
sommes pour vérifier nous le faisons au
titre du Parlement et du gouvernement
qui nous donne mission de le faire et
nous le faisons sereinement je trouve
que c'est plutôt une une bonne chose les
travaux en réalité sur le recensement de
ce qui est encore à faire les choses
avancent bien la question c'est
maintenant de bien définir la notion de
bon état c'est pas si évident que ça
quand c'est pas écrit c'est quoi une
autoroute en bon état à la fin
donc les négociations notamment sur
l'autorité de la DGITM ont bien avancé
et je pense notamment à l'ancien DGITM
qui d'ailleurs un produit qui
s'intéressait
au niveau de la RT
on avait interrogé et il était conscient
que c'était pas très très facile mais
qu'il faut qu'on avance là-dessus et les
choses doivent être claires parce que si
c'est pas clair avant ce sera pas clair
après et il y aura des débats donc il
faut qu'on se mette
au clair avant il faut qu'on se mette au
clair pour la fin des concessions et
pour la préparation des conseils
suivantes s'il y a de nouvelles
concessions il faut que ce soit net pour
que ces débats soient clairement
établies et reporté alors
sur le mauvais état du réseau ou non
Thierry projet Thierry projet et voilà
oui nous sommes plutôt intéressés par la
question théorie projet à condition de
fixer l'ensemble des conditions il
s'agit pas de le faire au doigt mouillé
comme on l'a fait à un moment donné il
s'agit de le prévoir avant et sur le
fait le résultat peut être très très
correct à lire certains articles de
presse la RT le Sénat et la mission IGF
CGED ne s'entendraient pas sur les
chiffres de rentabilité
il n'en est rien
à condition de regarder de quoi on parle
lorsque l'on compare des choses
comparables les différents rapports
produits sur le sujet sont similaires
lorsqu'elle a RT calcul inter y projet
de la concession elle obtient en moyenne
8% comme la mission IGF CGEDD
lorsque cette même mission
igfcged calcul tiers et actionnaires de
la privatisation elle trouve en moyenne
11,3% ce qui n'est pas si éloigné que ça
des 10,4% du Sénat nous sommes sur des
valeurs qui sont comparables alors
évidemment il y a des données qui
peuvent diverger mais ce n'est pas
autant que cela la question n'est pas
celle des chiffres c'est celle de leur
interprétation sur l'opposition entre
terre et projet de la concession a été
réactionnaire de la privatisation je
vais être clair chacune chacun des
indicateurs répondent à une question
différente mais utile calculer sur toute
la durée de la concession sur toute la
durée de la concession
Thierry projet permet d'analyser la
rentabilité sous l'angle du péage c'est
ce qui nous est demandé à nous à RT
par ceux qui sont nos tutelles
on nous demande de le faire et donc nous
répondons terribles nous faisons le
calcul qui nous est demandé et on l'a
mis par écrit pour qu'il y ait pas de
discussion avec les éléments de
comparaison il répond à une question
essentielle pour un régulateur
économique est-ce que le pH permet de
couvrir les dépenses liées aux
aménagements autoroutiers virgule majoré
d'un bénéfice raisonnable et donc nous
sommes souvent à discuter de ce bénéfice
raisonnable
mais nous n'avons pas sur les péages a
décidé puisque les formules des péages
sont fixés entre le concédant et le
concessionnaire
quand ensuite on applique ces formules
on arrive aux résultats en question la
question de fond c'est donc de fixer
correctement les formules au début et
d'avoir tous les éléments pour fixer ses
premiers le deuxième point le Teri
actionnaire de la privatisation mesure
la rentabilité pour leurs actionnaires
actuels de l'acquisition des sociétés
constitutionnaires d'autoroutes en 2006
il répond à une question qui relève de
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
est-ce que les concessions ont été
valorisées alors juste niveau à la
privatisation
je n'ai pas à répondre là dessus
nous sommes avec deux démarches
différentes non on dit calculer nous
quelle
la rentabilité depuis que les autoroutes
sont concédés on le fait volontiers et
ensuite il y a cette approche qui avait
été fait l'autorité quant à elle calcule
un trip projet de la concession car
c'est la mission que lui a confié le
législateur et on me dit encore ici en
conclusion sur la rentabilité du point
de vue de la RT un tiers et projet
estimé à 8 % sur toute la durée des
concessions c'est ce que nous avons dit
à coup de capital estimé à 7% sur toute
la période une rémunération des capitaux
des qui n'est donc pas manifestement
excessive mais des imperfections à
corriger c'est l'objet des propositions
des canaux que nous essayons de mettre
en place pour nous éviter les dérives
que nous avons pu connaître et qui ne
nous semblaient pas les les bonnes alors
j'espère que j'ai répondu à peu près à
l'ensemble des questions qui étaient
posées merci monsieur le Président
Jacques vernique ensuite Philippe
Tabarro et puis Louis Jean de Nicolas
pour la troisième question de cette
série
merci monsieur le Président intérim donc
monsieur le Président par intérim aussi
cher Philippe votre expérience
collégiale et présidentielle donc pour
cet intérim assez long à la RT vous
donne une expérience précieuse de la
régulation des transports on a cru
comprendre je me rappelle de l'audition
de votre prédécesseur que parfois il y
aurait je le cite une volonté de mettre
de côté une autorité indépendante qui
même si à la démontré son expertise gêne
parfois le gouvernement il a rajouté en
parlant d'un gouvernement qui serait
tenté de faire de la mayonnaise sans eux
autrement dit travailler à l'avenir des
autoroutes sans la RT donc j'ai compris
qu'il y a des approfondissements
nécessaires pour conforter la RT dans
ses missions et que le Parlement est
attendu en la matière
alors avec le plan d'avenir pour les
transports la donne semble bouger suite
au rapport du coi le discours de la
première ministre optant pour le
scénario dit de planification écologique
et les 100 milliards annoncés autrement
dit d'une certaine façon on a enfin des
niveaux d'investissement envisagés qui
correspondent à ce que la RT recommande
depuis longtemps pour financer ces
investissements donc la première
ministre on l'a dit a ouvert la piste
d'une importante contribution du secteur
autoroutier aussi de l'aérien chez bien
que c'est pas la RT qui qui en décidera
mais son éclairage est sans doute utile
pour l'autoroutier donc si j'ai bien
compris si nous avons bien compris
l'équilibre financier des concessions et
globalement atteintes et maintenant et
donc elles vont encore dégager quelques
dizaines de milliards de profits d'issus
d'ici l'issue des concessions actuelles
comment réguler le partage de ces
milliards entre l'État ses besoins
d'investissement dans les reports modaux
les usagers qui n'ont pas envie de payer
des péages trop importants et puis un
petit peu des actionnaires
en outre donc avec la fin des
concessions d'origine qui était assise
sur des investissements massifs le COI
parle d'une perspective à venir de
baisse des recettes de l'ordre de 50 à
70 % au regard des règles européennes
d'aujourd'hui donc cela risquerait pas
paradoxalement favoriser dans les
décennies à venir un mode qu'on cherche
au contraire à réduire et où dans ces
conditions trouver cette contribution du
secteur autoroutier pour les
investissements pour les transports
durables cette planification écologique
vous avez parlé des nouvelles
perspectives de l'eurovisionne de
taxation pollueurs payeurs
congestionnaire payeur doivent-elles pas
être exploitées à l'avenir et notre
fameuse taxe alsacienne à l'avenir que
vous connaissez bien en étant une sorte
de préfiguration
merci président Tabarro
président Richard je vais être plus
court que notre collègue Fernique j'ai
deux questions et vous avez répondu en
plus à une des deux questions la
première question était pourquoi c'est
décalage entre vos rapports se ligf et
ceux du Sénat vous nous avez apporté une
réponse probante ma deuxième question
vous l'avez évoqué mais je pense qu'elle
est plus compliquée pour avoir une
réponse claire mais je vais quand même
la poser l'autoroute peut-elle financer
de manière pérenne durable d'autres
modes comme le ferroviaire tout en se
décarbonant sans pour autant matraquer
les automobilistes par CPH tout en
reversant quelques dividendes
raisonnables à ces actionnaires
mais une équation en plusieurs inconnues
Louis géant de Nicolas
oui merci monsieur le Président mais
Philippe
exactement la même question que je
voulais poser donc mais on va se coté
brillant là à ce niveau-là oui monsieur
le Président merci de toutes ces
explications moi j'ai
deux petites questions la première c'est
sur le l'augmentation des pH et bien
0,85 % de l'inflation plus un
pourcentage en fonction des travaux je
vais juste savoir si c'était toujours
d'actualité ou ça n'est plus d'actualité
parce que je faisais partie moi de la
mission 2015 à l'époque où le président
de la République était ministre de
l'Économie et et sur la discussion de
des trois milliards 5 ou de 3 milliards
sans je me rappelle plus très bien de
travaux complémentaires en fonction de
l'allongement de la fonction la
concession et puis la deuxième question
Philippe abora Vienne en dire un mot
est-ce que dans l'avenir sur les
concessions on a déjà calculé ou
quelqu'un travaille sur le calcul de la
décarbonisation totale de des autoroutes
avec l'installation des bornes
électriques le fait qu'on puisse se
ramener les camions notre collègue à
parler tout à l'heure des routes
nationales sur les sur les autoroutes je
sais que Nicole Bonnefoy notre collègue
sur la nationale 10 est très préoccupé
par cette question-là et nous sur la
nationale 23 dans la Sarthe on est aussi
très préoccupé alors est-ce qu'il y a un
travail là-dessus pour faire en sorte et
bien qu'on allait-je sur les routes
départementales ou nationale le poids
des des poids lourds pour les mettre sur
les autoroutes et puis il y a des
carbonations le coût de la decarbonation
Merci
Président vous permettez une dernière
question celle on aura deux autres donc
on propose de répondre à ces trois
questions puis on prend on fera une
autre série
les milliards de de disponibles
évidemment ce sont des montants
importants
les entreprises qui investissent
au niveau de l'autoroute doivent être
payés pour les travaux qui sont faits
normal
et c'est normal aussi que pour tout
l'argent qui est avancé il y ait une
juste rémunération
d'un capital que cela peut rapporter
pour le travail qui est fait
tout ce qu'il faut c'est c'est que au
début on puisse encadrer le mieux
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a eu de telles
évolutions ça a été rappelé comme les
péages sont calculés sur l'inflation
quand vous avez des inflations qui
entre-temps a été aux alentours de 10%,
sachant considérablement ça donne quand
vous regardez les trois grandes
entreprises historiques sur ces périodes
de son sont très bien tirés
au-delà ce qu'on aurait pu imaginer
une troisième était juste dans ce qui
était prévu parce qu'elle n'avait pas
anticipé
l'éventualité de la hausse de péage
ce sont des réalités qui qui viennent
s'ajouter à ce qui s'est passé c'est
vrai que c'est ces dernières années
qu'on veut regarder les chiffres des
fameuses sociétés concessionnaires
pendant la période où la fréquentation
sur l'autoroute A complètement chuté
bon évidemment les résultats sont moins
bons que dans les périodes où ça
circulait à plein
enfin ça se rétablit quand même très
vite
ça se rétablit très vite parce que les
les taux des péages sont ajustés parce
que la fréquentation est que importante
parce que les matériaux doivent être
transportés et donc les choses se
rétablissent assez vite donc nous sommes
dans une situation
où on peut expliquer
ce qui est raisonnable jusqu'où nous
pouvons aller et aussi
à partir de quand c'est chiant avec un
travail complémentaire de ce que nous
avions fait on aurait pu peut-être aller
plus à leur certain disent est-ce que
les autres
modalités de transport par exemple
l'avion est-ce que le même travail est
fait je vous rassure nous faisons la
même chose pour les aéroports le sujet
n'est pas là-dessus mais on fait
attention aussi des économies entre
guillemets sur les voilà sur ce qui
était prévu prévu dans les aéroports
nous avons des résultats aussi à
présenter de la même façon
que ça revienne un peu moins cher que ce
qui était prévu dans les augmentations
de tarifs qui sont là donc on peut aller
plus loin alors Philippe Tabaro est-ce
que est-ce que les autoroutes pourront
financer tout est aussi une question
d'équilibre à un moment donné le
territoire qui se développe il y a
évidemment des retombées donc c'est
retombées sont utiles elles permettent
des refinancements peut imaginer que
l'autoroute sur une partie peut-être et
à financer d'autres d'autres modes
est-ce que c'est suffisant à mon avis
non mais quand on a créé
l'autorité de financement des
infrastructures au début on pensait que
ça allait ramener beaucoup plus d'argent
donc entre temps c'est reparti Parlement
a fait son travail je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les choses telles
qu'elles sont envisagées peuvent être
remarqué elles sont plus
plus
structurée mieux ficelé on peut
t'avancer donc à mon avis et il peut y
avoir un reversement
qui qui peut aller là-dessus il faut en
discuter à mon avis les sociétés
routières sont même prêtes à envisager
le cas moi au début plus aujourd'hui
donc c'est des choses qui peuvent
avancer c'est c'est la question c'est où
est-ce que je veux placer le débat au
niveau de l'État français s'il est à
français langage c'est bien merci
Jacques vernique d'avoir appelé les
propos de la première ministre en disant
qu'elle s'est renseignée et que
finalement elle prend maintenant les
chiffres de la RT depuis sa fonction
mieux moi ça me dérange pas ce genre de
choses je vais le redire je n'ai pas de
problème à titre personnel avec le
gouvernement
ni avec les sociétés autoroutières je
n'ai pas de difficulté
je n'étais pas candidat à la présidence
au début
parce que nous étions dans une période
de recomposition et qu'il arrive souvent
que nous ayons besoin aussi donner des
opportunités à des personnes qui ont des
qualités et que c'est tout à fait
légitime là où j'ai déclaré que j'étais
candidat c'est quand au bout de six mois
on avait toujours pas de désigner de
candidats et donc dit écoutez si ça peut
être une solution moi je suis prêt à
être candidat pour la présidence
visiblement j'ai pas été choisi après je
ne connais pas les raisons précises
exactes
je ne vois pas comment nous pourrions
sortir de l'existence de ces autorités
à titre personnel je trouve qu'elles
font plutôt du beau boulot je parle pas
de moi mais je parle de ces autorités
pour du bon boulot qui est utile qui
donne une vision une transparence qui
est efficace je trouve que ce serait
dommage de ne pas en profiter de ne pas
l'utiliser
alors à partir de là est-ce que
l'écoute qui vont venir notamment sur la
décarbonation est-ce qu'on a assez
d'argent pour le faire
on ne peut pas ne pas s'en occuper la
question environnementale est devenue
une question prioritaire il faut donc
évidemment le prendre en compte et
regarder comment on peut le financer
alors on a des approches sur sur le
coude de ce que cela peut représenter
on n'a pas en détail je me tourne vers
Jordan
oui on est tous prenez la parole on est
sans doute pas au
milliard au pluriel avec plusieurs
zéros dont on a parlé mais c'est la
question au-delà du milliard on est dans
ce tour de grandeur maintenant c'est
hors de grandeur on arrive à financer il
n'y a aucune raison que ne puisse pas le
financer donc on arrive à le financer
sur la question je je crois que c'est
Philippe qui qui les demandait sur
la hausse des péages d'abord elle est
prévue par les contrats la RT a en
revanche relevé un effet d'aubaine dans
un contexte d'augmentation très fort de
l'inflation li au fait que les péages
indexées à 70% sur l'inflation augmente
plus vite que les charges
voilà donc nous sommes effectivement
avec
des coûts élevés mais il suffit de le
prévoir et de laisser la flexibilité
nécessaire pour l'appliquer et ça peut
se faire ça peut se faire ce n'est pas
aussi catastrophique que ce qu'on peut
imaginer c'est toujours beaucoup
d'argent par définition parce que c'est
beaucoup d'argent qui est mobilisé
notamment par le privé donc c'est normal
qu'il soit payé correctement en retour
alors je ne sais pas si l'État a mis en
place une structure pour évaluer le coût
de la des carbonation en sont nous en
sommes à des approches qui sont plutôt
grossières mais c'est des choses qui
sont à faire et on n'est pas au bout
parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui la décarbonation en
grande partie c'est aujourd'hui
l'électrique mais nous savons aussi tous
en écoutant les spécialistes que nous
sommes sans doute pas au bout qui a
d'autres solutions à prévoir qui peuvent
coûter des moyens financiers qui sont à
regarder ajuster c'est évidemment le cas
pour notre pays c'est aussi le cas pour
les autres il s'agit donc de regarder où
les priorités seront mises et ce sont
des priorités que nous pouvons auquel
nous pouvons faire face au travers des
dispositifs qui qui sont à mettre en
place au niveau de la décarbonation tout
comme au niveau d'une contribution
notamment pour le pour le fret
ferroviaire
les chiffres ont été annoncés on veut un
doublement et tout ça en tête
si nous voulons aller vers le doublement
la première chose à faire c'est d'avoir
un bon réseau
quand vous n'avez pas de bons réseaux
vous pouvez pas faire circuler les
trains aussi vite que ce que vous
pourriez vous ne pouvez pas avoir la
même densité que ce dont on a besoin la
France a beaucoup de voies ferrées
l'entretien
est un peu moins bon en moyenne de ce
que il pourrait être
évidemment si la première ministre
trouve les moyens qu'elle a évoqué cela
permettra de faire face aux défis qui
sont des défis importants je pense que
le ferroviaire est un domaine dans
lequel beaucoup est à faire je ne crois
pas que le fait de céder au Conseil
régionaux les petites lignes soient une
solution facile parce que si c'est cher
pour l'État et la SNCF te les entretenir
ces petites lignes ça sera pas
nécessairement moins cher au niveau des
conseils régionaux c'est un avis
personnel donc si ça coûte aussi on va
avoir aussi au niveau des régions du mal
à établir l'équilibre et les difficultés
qu'on commence à rencontrer dans le
débat entre l'État et les régions
n'est peut-être aussi qu'une traduction
de cette formule toute simple c'est que
quand vous avez peu de gens dans les
trains c'est difficile de les
rentabiliser à titre personnel là où
j'étais
lorsque ce n'était pas entre guillemets
lorsque c'était trop
déséquilibré je ne faisais pas
mais j'essayais de faire en sorte que ça
soit le plus souvent bien équilibré donc
nous intervenions très en amont y
compris sur les lignes y compris sur
l'entretien des lignes 7 à 9 et
compagnie pour qu'on puisse continuer à
entretenir dans les meilleures relations
ce qui est là-dessus on le faisait en
Alsace depuis un bout de temps on l'a
fait ensuite aussi en Lorraine et
champagne dans la fois dans la
continuité de ce qui se faisait déjà
dans ces anciennes régions et parfois
avec un vrai
vrai accélérateur moi je repense
à la
aux Ardennes nous avions de vrais
difficultés quand on vient de Givet pour
aller sur Charleville quand j'ai pris la
première fois le train je voyais les
bicyclettes me dépasser
et bicyclettes ne dépassent plus être à
maintenant et ça fonctionne bien
et j'en suis heureux parce que ça permet
d'aller vers ce vers quoi nous tendons
plus plus de prise en compte
environnementale raisonnable sans que ce
soit tous les matins une révolution
c'est des choses qui permettent de
s'inscrire sur la durée même si c'est
pas aussi bon que ce qu'on aurait pu si
vous le permettez je vais peut-être
laisser mon voisin compléter ou soufie
sur des points que je n'aurais pas
évoqué suffisamment dans les réponses
merci monsieur le Président sur la
question de la décarbonation pardon des
autoroutes
honnêtement qui était posé en fait il y
a deux sujets il y a le sujet des
investissements à réaliser et le sujet
de leur financement le COI le reconnaît
lui-même dans son rapport il n'y a pas
d'évaluation aujourd'hui
consensuel ou en dossier en cas par la
puissance publique du montant
d'investissement à réaliser pour
décarboner les autoroutes vous avez une
société de concessionnaire d'autoroute
qui avec le cabinet de conseils a rendu
public une étude qui chiffre à plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros les
investissements nécessaires mais il y a
quand même des gros incertitudes qui
sont liés aux technologies de
dicarbonate de poids lourds et donc si
vous prenez la part on va dire la moins
discutable de ce montant
d'investissement vous êtes de l'ordre de
quelques milliards d'euros donc on va de
quelques milliards à quelques dizaines
de milliards et aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de travail équivalent à celui du coi par
exemple en matière de d'investissement
de la relation des autoroutes alors une
fois qu'on a dit ça se pose la question
de savoir comment les financer il y a
l'échéance des contrats concessions
actuels c'est une remise en concurrence
à si la puissance publique choisie de
maintenir un modèle concessif qui a ses
mérite en matière de de de de
financement des investissements par la
logique usagée payeur c'est qu'il y ait
des charges des futurs concessions qui
prévoieront des investissements à
réaliser pour s'inscrire dans cette
transition écologique des autoroutes
donc ça c'est à horizon 2031 à 2036
selon les chances des contrats
historiques après vous avez le court
terme entre aujourd'hui et une
éventuelle remise en concurrence des
autoroutes là la ce que ce qui est écrit
la RT dans son rapport de janvier 2023
c'est que il est possible en ayant
recours à une modalité de financement un
peu innovante qui est le recours à une
soulte et bien de financer dès à présent
des investissements des carbonation qui
seraient nécessaires à court terme
sans alourdir de manière trop importante
les péages les péages autoroutiers
puisqu'il n'y aurait qu'une partie de
ces investissements qui seraient amortie
jusqu'à la fin des contrats concessions
actuelles l'autre est emporté par le
futur concessionnaire et et évidemment
c'est c'est une façon de réaliser ces
investissements sans attendre le
renouvellement éventuel des concessions
sans alourdir les péages et sans avoir à
allonger les contrats de concession
historiques et l'autorité appelée l'Etat
à conduire les diligences les
investigations tu vas être de savoir si
cet outil peut ou non d'être utilisé
voilà la seule chose que je voulais
rajouter sur sur cette question de la
bicarbonation des autoroutes très bien
complément monsieur président sinon
passe nos deux dernières questions en
l'occurrence celle de Étienne blanc et
de Jean-Claude anglar pour terminer
incontestablement aujourd'hui et il faut
constater que la situation de nos
autoroutes cette améliorée qui sont de
qualité et qu'on est au niveau européen
ça veut dire pour être clair que le
système concis est un bon système si on
regarde l'objectif alors après et bien
il y a le problème de la décarbonation
alors après il y aura la question de
savoir si l'autoroute doit financer
d'autres modes de transport mais c'est
un autre sujet ça sera dans le contrat
non moi je voudrais vous poser une
question et parce que nous sommes dans
un pays et dans lequel malheureusement
lorsqu'une entreprise fait des résultats
très positifs elle est stigmatisés c'est
le cas aujourd'hui
oh là là c'est société concessionnaire
d'autoroute elles ont fait des résultats
et ses résultats n'ont profité qu'aux
actionnaires n'ont pas profité aux
Français et tout ça ça a été fait sur le
dos des usagers qui payent des droits de
pH qui sont excessifs en tout cas c'est
la majorité de la presse qui présente de
la sorte le système concessif et puis il
y a la sanctuarisation des entreprises
qui font des pertes
et en France une entreprise qui fait des
pertes et qui est subventionnées
finalement c'est pas si mal que cela
voilà on est dans un système qui marche
sur la tête
tout ça parce que lorsqu'il y a un
bénéfice lorsqu'il y a un résultat
positif
ce résultat positif en l'état actuel du
système concessif et bien évidemment il
profite à la société donc indirectement
à ses actionnaires et ma question elle
est simple monsieur le Président est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas un autre système
qui serait un système intermédiaire
dans lequel sur les résultats on
pourrait identifier la part qui va
l'investissement la part qui va à la
rémunération du capital ce qui est bien
normal puisque nous sommes dans une
entreprise et puis il y a une part que
vous avez appelé le bénéfice raisonnable
et on pourrait parfois constater qu'il y
a des bénéfices qui ne sont pas
raisonnables est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
mettre en place un système dans lequel
au titre du traité de concession lorsque
le bénéfice est
considéré comme déraisonnable il y a une
répartition entre l'entreprise et l'État
est-ce que c'est possible l'endroit
européen
à ma connaissance c'est parfaitement
possible en droit français en l'état
actuel est-ce que c'est une réflexion
qui est menée et si elle n'est pas menée
pourquoi ne n'est-elle pas
si pour cette question Étienne
Jean-Claude
merci monsieur le Président alors moi je
me suis Président je voudrais votre avis
sur un sujet qui concerne donc les ce
qui a été décidé il y a peu de temps
c'est à dire que l'État c'était l'estime
de 10 000 km de route au profit des
collectivités territoriales région ou
départements et on voit que sur le sujet
sur ces 10000 km aujourd'hui il y en a
que 2400 où le contrat je dirais est
arrivé au boost il y a bien accord entre
les collectivités et l'État donc c'est
un sujet qui n'avance pas beaucoup et si
je vous parle de ce sujet là c'est parce
que je pense à un sujet très précis et à
une autoroute non considérée très
précise qui est l'axe Toulouse Lyon
la 68 qui croise à 75 et qui traverse
donc notre département l'Aveyron c'est
pour ça que je me permets de vous
demander votre avis sur ce sujet est-ce
que vous pensez que l'État sur ce sujet
va rouvrir la possibilité d'avoir de
nouvelles concession ou pas
donc on se dit au concédé et bien sûr la
deuxième question c'est puisque l'État
et les difficultés aujourd'hui pour
participer au projet des collectivités
territoriales région ou départements
est-ce que vous pensez qu'en ouvrant les
nouvelles concessions on pourrait
trouver un moyen de financer des
autoroutes donc concédé et je pense très
clairement à la au 40 km qui reste à
faire n'est-ce pas entre Rodez de
l'Aveyron et le croisement de la 75 sous
notre département merci de votre avis
merci
ce Président je peux merci alors
je voudrais dire que par rapport
première intervention je
c'est des choses alors je vais peut-être
pas le dire automatiquement en termes de
président de l'autre côté mais à titre
personnel je trouve qu'on a quand même
énormément à avancer sur la qualité des
autoroutes il faut le reconnaître quand
on parle aujourd'hui nous autoroutes on
roule dans de bonnes conditions on n'a
pas besoin d'aller à tout prix beaucoup
beaucoup plus loin on a fait de vrais
progrès il faut le reconnaître et si on
a fait ces progrès y compris dans
l'entretien régulier y compris dans des
questions d'environnement pour la
récupération des autres plis le long etc
on le doit d'abord à ces sociétés
autoroutières qui l'ont fait
donc moi je le reconnais volontiers et
je pense que oui il faut être fier quand
on a des sons des entreprises qui se
développent qui font ce qu'on leur
demande
et si ensuite on s'est rendu compte que
dans le débat on a peut-être on aurait
pu aller un peu plus loin faisons le
nécessaire pour corriger donc nous on
est là pour dire là il nous semble utile
de corriger on va on précise parfois
même comment on pourrait le cas échéant
corrigé pour qu'on soit plus plus
efficace
et donc nous avons dit nous au niveau de
l'autorité tous que ce modèle qui était
là était un modèle qu'on peut prendre à
condition d'enlever ce qui n'est pas bon
ça dure la durée trop longue trop
d'incertitudes des renégociations dans
un cadre qui n'est pas
concurrentiel
donc il faut préciser cela je trouve
aussi l'Autorité de régulation pourrait
avoir en la matière des compétences un
peu nouvelles et je le redis c'est pas
des questions de ils ont les chevilles
qui a envie savent pas comment vouloir
encore plus de pouvoir
j'estime que nous sommes des gens à peu
près normaux qui fonctionnant à peu près
raisonnablement et on essaye d'apporter
des solutions y compris au niveau
technique pour qu'on puisse avancer de
façon raisonnable donc moi je pense
qu'on peut le faire et donc tout est là
et s'il faut redéfinir un petit peu dans
dans les cadres futurs à la fois la
question du risque parce que parfois le
risque est
cher payé donc il y a des situations ou
sur certains nombres d'opérations on
pourrait voir autrement la couverture du
risque avec en particulier l'état on
pourrait le faire pour avoir moins
d'incertitudes pour avoir un fond qui
soit moins lourd à porter sur le futur
donc moi je trouve que que nous avons la
donne entre nos mains
et je trouve que globalement avec ce que
j'ai en retour de ce que j'apprends de
ce que décide le gouvernement je suis
pas au courant deuxième question je ne
veux pas pouvoir répondre parce qu'il me
téléphone pas en me disant voilà ce que
j'ai envie de faire donc je ne suis pas
au courant mais
il me semble que les voix qu'on est en
train de prendre que nous sommes en
train de prendre correspondre à ce qu'on
avait nous on était vraiment inquiet du
fait que rien ne bouge ça bouge
aujourd'hui on est pas d'accord avec
tout certes mais on voit bien que les
les balises se mettent en place il faut
qu'elle soit les plus efficaces possible
il faut qu'on puisse progresser de façon
intéressante à la question de
Jean-Claude est-ce que 10000 km
délesté pour aller vers des
collectivités ça peut simplifier
oui
et certains collectivités peuvent avoir
un réel intérêt à le faire
il y a pas de raison on peut le faire ça
peut être une solution ça peut être une
solution
à condition de regarder dans l'équilibre
général la nécessité de de faire ces
opérations
une fois que c'est porté mais ça peut
être une façon de faire je trouve qu'au
niveau des collectivités
c'est une façon de transférer des
compétences moi j'ai été
fondamentalement des centralisateurs
mais décentralisateurs dans l'idée de ce
qui était à l'époque celui qui avait
porté la décentralisation mise de
l'intérieur c'était dans l'idée
que l'État laisse expérimenter
que la décentralisation c'est aussi
faire des choses
aux collectivités qui n'étaient pas
automatiquement prévu c'est qu'on puisse
adapter la décentralisation c'est pas
l'état qui décide tout et qui ensuite
dit aux collectivité maintenant pour le
faire je vous laisse voilà le
l'opportunité de le faire ou pas il faut
qu'on ait
fois en la décentralisation parce que
c'est la seule façon de retrouver la
confiance de nos concitoyens la
confiance de nos concitoyens passe par
le fait qu'on décide localement par des
implications par des choix qui sont
faits sur la base de ce qui se passe sur
le terrain et je pense que ça c'est
indispensable pour tous pour ceux
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et ça aurait
été indispensable aussi pour ce dire
déjà la décentralisation c'est pas juste
je décide moi et puis vous vous pouvez
le faire pour essayer de regarder
comment vous pouvez vous en tirer au
mieux et donc les 10 km ça peut pas être
juste quelque chose qui peut voilà
je trouve que 10 km d'autoroute dit
qu'il met d'autres c'était intéressant
moi je m'étais battu à l'époque en tant
que président de région pour que les
routes reviennent à la région en termes
d'organisateurs du développement
territorial ça me paraissait cohérent
puis les gouvernements ont changé ils
ont fait le contraire bah ils ont le
droit c'est la démocratie mais à un
moment donné il faut que dans la dans la
décentralisation il faut qu'on ait plus
de durée il faut qu'on réaffirme
régulièrement ce que c'est et qu'on
laisse des opportunités des opportunités
de de
découvrir comment on peut aller plus
loin alors tout à l'heure on me
demandait pourquoi certains me disent
pourquoi ils t'ont pas choisi pour être
président très franchement j'en sais
rien j'en sais rien mais
le secrétaire général de l'Élysée qui
n'est pas n'importe qui
m'a mis par écrit
ce n'est pas possible parce qu'on ne
peut pas te nommer deux fois
un membre de l'autorité ne peut être
nommée qu'une fois mais une fois qu'on y
est dans la durée en question
rien d'interdit si on est vice-président
de devenir président me semble-t-il
c'est ce que je lui ai répondu il a dit
il va vérifier puis il me répondra il
m'a plus répondu
mais
il a dit c'est la SGG qui a dit ça j'ai
dit à mon avis elle se trompe et nous
avons nous-mêmes vérifié nous pensons
plutôt que c'était possible
et quand je dis nous pensons que c'était
plutôt possible c'est-à-dire que je suis
sûr que c'était possible mais l'analyse
était différente et quand on est
plusieurs on peut avoir des analyses
différentes
donc moi je pense que les les choses
avancent plutôt bien
faut regarder pour qu'on puisse bien
cadrer qu'on puisse bien accompagner
pour que y compris l'autorité puisse
avoir son rôle
intelligent à définir dans le futur et
dans cette co-construction moi je suis
prêt à rentrer dans ce débat de
co-construction
vraiment rien à perdre tout ce que je
fais encore vous avez un couleur des
cheveux montre que l'avenir politique
est passé donc ça vaut pas la peine de
discuter de ça donc c'est fini donc moi
je suis là je peux essayer de regarder
comment là où je suis je peux apporter
quelque chose j'ai par ailleurs des
choses que je fais dont je suis très
heureux je suis président d'une
association qui s'occupe de personnes
handicapées de protection d'enfance 1500
salariés là-bas j'ai un budget de 100
millions
et c'est bien
je suis très heureux de le faire
et voilà donc on espère que
trouvera mais je suis sûr qu'on trouvera
avant la fin des concessions à nouveau
président pour la RT
merci
monsieur le Président et non mais il y a
une chose c'est vraiment intéressant au
début c'est hard quand on rentre dedans
c'est dur y compris je pense pour toi
aussi tu as d'abord mais une fois qu'on
y est et qu'on se donne c'est vraiment
intéressant
pas possible qu'on trouve pas un
président c'est pas possible
très bien merci monsieur le Président
merci à vous d'avoir répondu aux
nombreuses questions des collègues que
je remercie pour leur présence et la
pertinence de leurs questions au travers
de vos réponses bien sûr vous a apporté
un grand élément mais vous avez surtout
démontrer que vous étiez plus qu'un
président par intérim président part
entière de cette structure à laquelle
nous sommes attachés et vous avez aussi
conforté je pense les parlementaires
dans la place et le rôle important que
doit jouer la RT dans la régulation
puisque c'est sa mission mais aussi dans
dans la projection dans dans les
perspectives et l'adaptation que ce soit
d'ailleurs sur les concessions
autoroutières ou sur tous les autres
sujets l'adaptation de de
des conditions d'exploitation de de
contrôle de l'ensemble des des sujets
qui sont confiés à la RT qui ne
demandent qu'à agrandir évidemment
merci beaucoup merci à vous Mesdames et
Messieurs et bon courage